hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
moto Z might be one of the prettiest
phones I've ever held but you don't
really buy a phone just because it's
pretty I mean some people do but you
don't really want to lock yourself into
like a two-year contract just cuz
something was pretty and attractive and
shiny in the store you got to get to
know it first so that's exactly what I'm
going to be doing over the next couple
days and weeks for my full review of
this phone to know exactly how good it
is and where it stands so we're off the
bat this is a flagship so it's supposed
to represent the top end of what
Motorola has to offer and they take a
few risks here and there too now there's
actually two phones the Moto Z is a
super thin one the five point two
millimeters thin with metal rails and
glass on the front and back phone and
the Moto Z force is actually the
slightly thicker one with a larger
battery high-resolution camera and a
shatterproof display and the force is
actually only seven millimeters thin but
it actually feels thick next to the
regular Moto Z which is pretty
ridiculous now I've said it before and
I'll say it again this is definitely one
of the sleekest and I think one of the
prettiest phones I've ever held for some
reason of some reason I just really like
the way it looks especially with no
fingerprints on it and especially with
the black front so you don't see any of
the sensors once you actually take a
look around the phone there's definitely
a couple erasers there's a big old
camera bump on both phones there's a big
enough bump that it rocks if you try to
type on a table there's some awkwardly
placed buttons up here on the top right
hand corner can't say I'm a fan of those
right off the bat and there's only one
speaker up top with the earpiece it does
face you but there's no counterpart on
the other side so it doesn't seem like
audio is a big priority and if you look
around this phone enough you'll realize
that there is no headphone jack at all
yet they pulled an apple before Apple
pulled an apple there's only one IO on
the entire phone it's just a single USBC
port at the bottom so just for good
measure they included this dongle this
adapter in the Box this USB c2 headphone
adapter so you can listen to music
yeah welcome to 2016 anyway I'm going to
try to look past all that because this
phone has a lot going for it
it's a flagship spec for a flagship
price that will be revealed soon but
Snapdragon 820 4 gigabytes of RAM a 13
or 21 megapixel camera depending on if
you get the Moto Z or Moto Z force and a
5.5 inch 2k AMOLED display right up
front above this little square
fingerprint reader which shows quick to
set up and has been working great so far
there is a micro SD card slot up top for
expandable storage and it's sticking
with the classic Motorola stock ish
Android with a couple tweaks and
additions so pretty clean software
experience here too so good on Lenovo
for keeping with that but since it's a
Verizon exclusive for the first couple
weeks it becomes a droid Edition phone
and gets this lovely Verizon bloatware
that we all love so much huh some things
like the battery life and the camera
quality will of course have to be tested
throughout the course of the review and
definitely let me know what else you
guys want to see tested for that full
review when it comes out but right now
my hopes are sort of in the middle of
the road for how thin it is for making
the battery so small but there's also
fast charging so we'll see
now here's a kicker these pins on the
back of the phone are for attaching a
bunch of accessories called moto mods
and they don't really fully use the word
modular but you kind of get the idea
there's a bunch of attachable
accessories that you can add to your
phone with a snap and a bunch of magnets
and pins so you don't have to reboot
your phone or pull the battery out or
anything like that and I have a bunch of
options right out the gate to start with
so they have style shells that just
change the look of the back of the phone
to whatever material or color you want
but they also have these little battery
power packs to add 2200 million powers
to the phone this one is almost seems
like a day one default ad because it
shrinks the camera hump and it brings a
total battery capacity to being way
bigger and then there's some more
interesting ones like a JBL speaker pack
with a huge battery and a really loud
speaker in it and a Motorola made inste
projector again with its own internal
battery and a projector and a kickstand
so you can cast whatever is on your
phone onto the wall I'm probably gonna
make an entire dedicated video about
these mods because I have a lot to say
about the idea but so far it seems like
the selection is decent you kind of have
more third parties hop in and make their
own assuming this phone cell as well so
you have a bunch more choices
already have incipio on board for some
to me a battery company is making some
others so that's kind of the kicker
feature of this phone so some people
will probably find it really cool and
make that worth picking up the phone
itself either way that's just the first
impression I won't know a lot more about
this phone shortly but until then be
sure to be subscribed if you haven't
already to be able to see what's up next
and that's pretty much it thanks for
watching I'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace